but yesterday trump
is giving a speech
and uh you know
uh he says ilan ilan ilan he's not going
to buy twitter trump said after
encouraging those in the attendance to
use a competing social media platform
truth social and where did you hear that
before from me
he's got himself a mess i've looked at
his contract you know elon says he's
never voted republican but i didn't know
that because he told me that he voted
for me so he's another [ __ ] artist
anyway so the moment ilan says this
trump has to jump in and make a comment
so what are your thoughts about what's
going on with this year adam well uh
you're talking about the twitter or the
trump terror both give me both well
i would hope there's a couple different
things going on number one i would love
to see elon
buy twitter i think twitter's a absolute
[ __ ] show the whole thing that's
happening with the bots
you have you know people speculating
that five percent of the user bases bots
and then you have donald trump jr
speculating that 50 of the user bases
bots
um
as far as the trump situation of course
he needs to weigh in and poke fun at
elon
if i'm trump i'd like to have elon as an
advocate an ally not an enemy that's not
someone that i want to be feuding with
keep in mind you know as far as being a
[ __ ] artist that's like the pot
calling the kettle black by the way
there's a part of trump that's in you
know there's an ego driven thing trump's
worth what
two three billion dollars
where elon musk is worth what two
three hundred billion
so you know
if i'm trump number one i'm i'm i want
to have elon on my side he admitted that
he would vote republican this time
straight up
whether that's the sanders or trump
remains to be seen but
that's not the type of person you want
to be fighting with furthermore
obviously trump's always got an angle
because what's his social media network
true truth truth social aren't they
trying to replace twitter
so of course there's going to be some
feuding with
with elon but trump's because as a
businessman what do you think is going
on with him with the deal
pulling is he playing a game
no no
listen like you made an offer on a house
and you offered a million bucks okay
during the 60 days closing period
uh all of a sudden uh of i don't know a
war happens covet happens
you know a massive
disruption happens to the market
and
rates skyrocket whatever percent real
estate valuation drops 20 so that
million dollar house you're buying all
of a sudden it's worth 800 000
you go back to the buyer and say look
i'm not buying this for a million
dollars you're figuring out a way to get
out of the deal that's what he's trying
to do either i'll buy it for a lot less
after doing the inspection or
uh i'm not gonna buy it and i'm gonna
lose whatever money that i'm putting
sometime when you're buying a house and
you put like this this one building i
bought not this one the other building
that i bought the federal building
there was already a deal in place i went
in with a cash offer and i said look
i'll buy this cash he said show us you
know you know if you're really serious
about this i said what do you want me to
do he said put a few hundred thousand
dollars in an account that if we don't
close the deal you lose that money now
that's a decision
so you see what happened right there so
what'd i say okay no problem so i put a
few hundred thousand dollars in an
escrow account sign an agreement that if
i don't close it it's not mine but i
bought it cash and i bought it
discounted week later that i get an
offer for six million dollars on that
building but i bought it for cash right
so
in this case
if he walks away he pays that one
billion but these guys now want to sue
him and the ceo i don't know if you guys
saw what the ceo of twitter said the ceo
of twitter said we're going to war can
you pull this one up we're going to war
with ilan and you know
uh um ceo of twitter typed in ceo of
twitter war musk and you'll see an
article that's going to pop up
uh there you go twitter ceo
agrawal willing to go to war to make
elon musk's deal happen so go a little
lower go a little lower go little lower
syria venezuela willing to go toward to
make elements 44 billion dollar
acquisition social media giant emmett
reports that the deal could be in
jeopardy over the site's handling of
spam and bots after the market closed
must disclose as icc filing he was
terminating the deal program who assumed
the chief executive
job last fall after the company's
co-founder jack dorsey stepped down from
the role is reportedly starting to come
out fighting after the mosque repeatedly
criticized okay
so he has to do that
because if he doesn't show that the
investors agrawal would be due to
receive a payroll 42 million under the
current terms of the buyout as with a
handful of twitter executives agarwal
payout will be triggered by a so-called
change in control clause under contract
which kicks in after
kicks in either of them is terminated
within 12 months and no ownership
assuming to help hem of the company so
he has to do that because he has to be
strong in front of his shareholders and
in front of his board he has to
show that fight now is he going to win
i don't know there's a lot of people
that are hoping that he can force him to
buy twitter there's a lot of people that
are hoping he ends up buying twitter by
the way there's a guy named professor
galloway
scott galloway i don't know if you guys
follow this guy or not
great content he had a she was supposed
to have a show with cnn plus until cnn
plus uh it didn't make you with a 300
million dollars cnn they didn't make it
cnn what cnn negative cnn negative good
point well it's actually not a bad name
for a show there we go so scott's been
uh playing a lot of games with elon just
kind of driving him you know saying you
were never going to buy it you know you
were just kind of using he's trolling
elon hardcore he's trolling him
eventually to the point where elan just
uh blocked him
and then he came and said here's
somebody that's for freedom of speech
why are you blocking me why are you
worried about what i have to say so
there's a lot of commentary that's going
on there with this
um i just think elon made an offer that
was 42 44 billion and twitter's now
probably worth
20 to 30 percent less and he's sitting
there saying look i lost 60 billion
dollars on my net worth that was worth
300 billion so if i would have bought it
at 300 billion net worth i've lost 20
percent i'd like to buy this 40 whatever
two billion dollar company for 20 less
which is what 34 billion if you want to
do that deal i mean i think that's kind
of what's going on but twitter wants
that additional 8 billion i may be wrong
well now twitter's
threatening to sue for a billion bucks
no no you're not the billion they're
gonna get no matter what because that's
the billion like when i said i i made
that offer on that building if i close
that building or not they're getting
that cash in the escrow so you're saying
that he has to pay that or that's
already a billion is an escrow that
billion i i assume that billion is going
to go to twitter no matter what but
twitter is sitting there saying no no we
lost more than a billion dollars so pb
here's the question we just got through
with the whole johnny depp amber heard
you know trial of the decade whatever
what are the chances this goes to court
and how much bigger would this be you
know media wise than the johnny depp
amber which one which one
twitter versus elon musk it's that's not
going to be 1 100 of what the amber
heard situation oh you think johnny depp
and amberhead is gonna be bigger than
elon versus twitter dude like
look at your podcast when you do your
podcast and there's girl drama guy drama
whatever girl drama is what people are
are you serious amber amber heard as the
goat of drama like gonna have because
she have to even go to court right by
the way there i i find it very ironic
that amber heard who she was with before
johnny depp it was freaking elon musk
yeah
no that's kind of not before johnny depp
wow she was with johnny depp her and
elon dated for a few it wasn't before i
thought it was before no no sir and
johnny have been around for for a while
her and elon musk had a fling i think
like uh last year or a couple years ago
so you don't think that if elon musk
went to trial versus twitter it would be
mainstream news galore zero
it would not be 1 100
of johnny depp and amber hurt really are
you serious about this question elon
musk is arguably the most famous person
in the world
do you think he that people
i don't think he'd have but it would be
a litigation trial
exciting it'd be like a litigation it
wouldn't be fun or exciting or dramatic
unless he shows up in court and shits
like and it's not going to be
now if january 6 trump goes to trial now
amber heard
yeah came over you're going to talk
about eight million people live watching
that one that's a different story okay
so but this one i don't think so this
look there's a big camp that's hoping
the scans are buying twitter
what camp are you in i want to see him
buy twitter
i want to see what he's saying
is when you get on
the the you and i are protected when
starbucks has a coffee bean
you and i are protected when a
mcdonald's has a burger king you and i
are protected when a 24-hour fitness has
an la fitness you and i are protected
when a cnn has a fox you and i are not
protected because there is zero
competitors on social media virtual
governments on the opposite side none
every one of them is one side and all
the other ones that are on the opposite
side they're very very small so in this
case yeah i do want him to buy twitter
yeah i'd like to see other people also
buy other platforms i'd love to see a
conservative buy new york times i'd love
to see uh fiscally conservative
capitalists buy fortune magazine i'd
like to see some of those things
happening but uh yeah so i would like to
see the sky one because i want to see 50
50. that's how i
uh get clear to the truth because i want
to see debate so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
you